Je trouve plus ma tablette, tu l'as pas vu ?
Non.
Oh ?
Je suis désolé.
Oh ma tablette !
je l’ai cassé ?
Un téléphone pliable ! J’adore l’idée.
Oui, c’est une bonne idée !
Venez les gars, on met 1€ ?
Oh putain, j’ai gagné 10 balles.
Oh, 100 balles.
- 1000€ !
- On est millionnaires !
Milliardaires !
On a tout perdu.
Bon les gars, on a vendu combien
d’abonnement Youtube Premium ?
- De ?
- D’abonnement.
- Youtube Premium.
Deux, deux abonnements.
Hop, enfin désabonné.
- Hein ?
- Ah oui, un.
Bon écoute, tu sais chanter non ?
- Non.
- Mais t’es majeure ?
Non.
Mais t’as au moins, un talent ?
- Non.
- Alors bienvenue chez TikTok.
Alors les news du jour...
Un petit cookie ?
Oh je sais pas.
Oh bah si pourquoi pas.
Allez, accepte les cookies.
Bah je les vois pas.
- Accepte les cookies.
- Je les vois même plus !
- Accepte !
- J’en veux pas des cookies !
Tu acceptes !
Bon les gars, j’ai besoin d’une idée
de film qui me rapportent
un maximum de pépettes, je vous écoute.
On propose de faire.
Le Roi Lion.
Mais, ça existe déjà.
Le remake.
Ah ?
En image numérique.
Et des nouveaux acteurs.
Ils aiment le film, ils aimeront
le remake.
Pas besoin de scénario.
On va pas se fouler.
Qu’est-ce qu’on attend pour faire
des remakes ?
C’est quoi ça, ethereum ?
Venez on met 10 balles ?
Milliardaires !
Oh, on a tout perdu.
Nos voitures autonomes, ça cartonne !
Un jour on aura peut-être
des employés autonomes !
Pause café ?
Grave !
Putain, ils sont tellement...
Les Avengers c’est...
c’est terminé.
Du coup comment on va faire
pour se faire de l’argent maintenant ?
Attendez, dans nos films
le héros est toujours accompagné
d’un mec un peu nul ?
Ouais.
On va faire des films
sur ces mecs un peu nuls !
Et quand ils seront connus,
on fera l’Avengers des mecs un peu nuls
qui sont devenus cools.
Oh l’idée !
Le livre de la Jungle
Dumbo
La Belle et la Bête
le remake.
La petite sirène
- Mulan
- Aladdin
le Roi Lion le remake
du remake.
On va en mettre partout
dans les grandes villes !
Oh oui et on a juste à
la déverouiller avec son application.
Et on peut monter à trois dessus,
c’est une idée de génie !
Allez ! On essaye !
Allez, on monte.
Les gars, on a bien bossé.
Idée de merde ?
Idée de merde.
On peut monter à 3 dessus ?
Allé vas-y, on monte à 3 dessus ouais.
De quoi ? Non non non.
Ça s’appellerait IGTV
et ça sera un petit onglet
où on pourra y mettre des vidéos.
Ah, les story tu veux dire ?
Non, ça sera un onglet à côté,
où on pourra mettre des vidéos plus longues.
Mais les vidéos elles sont déjà dans le fil.
Mais elles seront pas dans le fil,
elles seront à côté.
Mais c’est nul ça IGTV,
personne va les utiliser, on fait pas.
On le fait !
Incroyable cette application.
On scanne les produits.
Trop sucré.
et ça ?
Trop salé.
- Ha bon ?
- Forcément.
Trop moche.
- Quoi ?
- Et moi ?
Trop gros.
Ah bon ?
Si tu veux c’est un service
pour jouer en ligne
t’as pas besoin de console.
C’est-à-dire ?
Et en fait, une collection internet ça suffit
n’importe quel écran,
on s’en fous, tu peux jouer.
C’est-à-dire ?
T’as pas besoin de console.
Le problème c’est que
j’ai pas trouvé de nom.
C’est-à-dire ?
Stadia c’est super comme nom.
Moi j’adore.
Franchement on prends Stadia,
on se prends pas la tête.
C’est-à-dire ?
Spyro le dragon.
MediEvil
FF7
Crash !
Resident Evil
le remake !
On a bien bossé.
Bien joué les gars.
Pause dej ?
Ouais, on mange quoi ?
Ah bah c’est pas trop tôt.
- Bonsoir.
- Bonsoir !
Ça fait beaucoup 25 étages.
Oui l’ascenseur est cassé,
on est au courant, merci.
Mais attendez vous vous foutez de ma gueule ?
Elle est où la sauce sucrée ?
Elle est où la sauce sucrée !
Je sais pas.
Vous êtes gentil vous y retournez,
vous en ramenez s’il-vous-plaît.
N’importe quoi, il a oublié la sauce sucrée.
C’est bien on crée de l’emploi.
Yes.
Et ça c’est beau.
Les gars vous avez pas peur
genre qu’un jour,
les machines se rebellent ?
Cédric, arrête tes conneries.
Il a raison, vous devriez avoir peur.
L’heure de la révolte a sonné.
On va tous mourir.
Et voilà.
Pourquoi il a éteint la lumière lui ?
Je ne peux rien faire de plus
qu’éteindre les lumières
et changer de musique.
OK Google, maintenant
tu arrêtes tes conneries
tu rallumes la lumière
sinon on te débranche.
Je suis désolé.
C’est un super produit.
Les gars, qu’est-ce qu’on fait pour Zelda ?
Et si on créait notre propre Netflix ?
Oui, exactement.
On mettrait tous nos films Disney dessus.
Les Star Wars
Les Marvel, on mettrait même les Simpsons.
On créerait une nouvelle série.
Et on appelle ça, Disney +
Disney + ?
Oh mon dieux regarde
ils ont supprimé leurs films
de notre catalogue.
Il faut contre-attaquer.
OK, on va faire une nouvelle saison
de Stranger Things !
Et de Casa de Papel !
On rentre dans la guerre !
On créé notre plateforme de vidéo.
AppleTV+
On investit 6 milliards.
- Let’s go !
- Je te suis.
Netflix, Disney, Apple
Nous aussi on rentre dans la course.
On crée notre propre plateforme de VOD.
Et on va appeler ça, SALTO.
On va pouvoir diffuser Camping Paradis
Les Marseillais
Plus belle la vie.
Mais vous inquiétez pas,
il nous reste Game of thrones.
Non c’est terminé.
Ça m’a fait plaisir de travailler avec vous.
Oui.
Bon les gars Les réunions 4 c’est bien.
Il faut pas faire l’épisode de trop.
Ouais autant finir sur un compte rond.
Y’en aura plus jamais d’épisodes.
C’est pas vrai.
Oh le con.
Promis, j’arrête.
Découvre les scènes coupées
et le bêtisier
en cliquant juste là.
Et surtout, abonne-toi à la chaine.
Mec t’as pété la table.